[Music]
in never happy news submitted by Jimmy
ballers 20 the world's oldest ever human
says she's never felt happy I read this
this morning [ __ ] hilarious all this
woman never human okay
human all this violence they lost her
birth records right but there she claims
she's like 128 or some okay they lost it
but she's so [ __ ] bitter and she
calls it like a curse to still be alive
she's about 17 it just feels like a
hundred 28 to her but what it's funny
cuz everybody's all like everyone always
asked me what's the [ __ ] secret I
don't know like it's just the cursed God
won't let me die
it's so funny because that's the image
everyone has it's like Oh a long happy
life you probably are so happy because
you're living still and all that
terrified because my back hurts now I
don't know what's gonna happen that like
60 70 80 I'm saying like I'm pretty sure
these people wake up and they wake up in
the morning it's just like [ __ ] I hate
this [ __ ] it's like a trek to go to the
bathroom
you gotta like hobble over there there's
a there's a lady in like Japan to like
she lives but she was like a hundred and
something I think we saw it on JK news
but she was functioning though she was
gardening she was cleaning a place I
wouldn't mind being old like that yeah
you still eat cook Rome food that's fine
you know
well she they're saying that she's like
self-sufficient we just thought that
it's just that they're her eyesight
giving out that's the only thing but
anyway so the Russian government is
claiming to have found the oldest woman
in the world at 128 years old they just
want to win at something cheating though
we can't find her birth record you got a
carbon dater ass yeah yeah [ __ ] she is
so apparently she was born in 1889 and
next month she'll be 129 she sees so
many wars yeah that's what they're
claiming that she has lived through so
many business
yeah so she outlived all her kids mm-hmm
and then the last daughter that diet was
104 whoa yeah and so she's saying she's
a vampire she's from Russia right next
to Transylvania
yeah sure her name is Coco what'd she
look like does she look like every other
old Esper's what does she look like a
vampire
yeah no she doesn't go like 120 years
old though yeah it's funny cuz she liked
her beds outside like she lives outside
she had like compact like her beds
outside she really wants to die she's
like let the elements dig me please that
bad less I guess 90 years old hella cute
and here's like her passport it says
like 1889 oh my gosh yeah that's not
even an option when you they asked for
your birthday it doesn t fit go back to
the 1800 it's it's all handwritten and
[ __ ] yeah so then she's a stone tablet
Passport it's 20 pounds so she's saying
that when she's asked like how did you
live so long she says it was God's will
I did nothing to make it happen I see
people going in for sports eating some
especially keeping themselves fit but I
have no idea how I've lived so long I
have not had a single happy day in my
life I have always worked hard digging
in the dark in the garden I am tired
long life is not at all God's gift for
me what a punishment wait so she would
she'd never had one happy day not one
happy patient like her [ __ ] was sad like
because she's Chechen or something and
then the Russians the Russian Civil War
yeah they kicked out the Chechens or
whatever and then she in Kazakhstan or
whatever they didn't want them there she
says that she remembers the Germans
passing by with tanks passing by her
house in tanks and I was scary but yeah
like she just lived through so many wars
and apparently during the second chechen
war from 1999 to 2009 that's when she
lost her document i
feel like she like had a conversation
with God that was like really negative
she said will you do keep me alive
forever you don't exist
he's like well I [ __ ] them it's pretty
funny though because everyone thinks
like the general consensus is like oh
you live so long and old you must be so
happy like that's that's the key to
psyche that's the secret to like living
all as being happy this is like the
perfect example inner that's how you
live long you should be the depression
spokesperson like look at me depressions
not bad but she's the press has been
depressed her whole life she was she was
depressed you just said she never had
one happy day doesn't know what
depression is now you don't have a
single up in your life it's her life she
was born it's been a valley no peak none
of that is just German tanks Russian
Wars Chechen Wars or maybe maybe that
the key to life is complaining or
letting it all out we're doing all day
it sucks we're gonna live forever dude
and she's digging and stuff every day
what about Christmas what's her
Christmas like I wonder sucks
well they just make a joke but ever they
light it on fire Merry Christmas day
they just pop balloons yeah and her
[ __ ] face every birthday they killed
the puppy in front of my face oh no it's
like 90 some [ __ ] percent genetics to
like because there's like this last
surviving World War two veteran or
something out of his unit and he's like
he's in Texas he's just like he's like
this black guy that lives out in Austin
and he's like a hundred something years
old and he drinks it everyday smokes
every day he's like what's the secret to
life
having fun I guess like you know he
doesn't know no one knows happiness
levels I heard our genetic - oh really
yeah like you're born with a certain
like a certain resting point of half
some people just satisfy we down here
like you can get to this level of
happiness but you could ever get up up
here that muscle
and then some people are born up here
and they'll never know like how to be
that sad I know some [ __ ] people that
are like dumbass [ __ ] that are like here
happy as [ __ ]
ignorance is bliss I'm telling you dude
yeah that's why you just got to not give
a [ __ ] all the time even stuff you
should give a [ __ ] about just don't care
about like bills [ __ ] but that's hard
when you understand exactly you're not
you're choosing yeah you understand the
concept when you're like a [ __ ]
goldfish dude
life is great eyes are bulging out of
you
you're gonna bowl like what what's this
area oh my god what's a serie well I
want to be a fish all right no you know
what's interesting is has nothing to do
with like goldfish or anything else bad
and why this popular baby don't talk
about it I have to talk no it doesn't
okay it's like it's it's weird how like
if you have a friend right your friend
is your your like you just see them as a
friend if they're a girl right but the
rest of the world may find that person
attractive and you don't really notice
it so like more like a bimbo
yeah so we're not like that oh we're in
Vegas it was Cantabria where they were
walking together right and the marital
was we were white right behind them and
you know breeze just walking and the
mayor looks at me and she goes what the
[ __ ] and I'm like what you mean what the
[ __ ] she was like guys are so
interesting I said what do you mean and
I'm like so just just notice Bri and
they'll notice every guy that's walking
by right I was like okay and I didn't
see anything she goes watch again as
she's walking like attractive guys doing
this they're going every [ __ ] guy
whether they were holding the cat handed
their child on their wife it didn't
[ __ ] matter they're just walking
she's just walking and the disguiser
just like I never noticed that [ __ ] did
and so could you mention the goldfish ah
they just follow [ __ ] guys are just so
like they don't you know your wife is
right next to you and then like I saw
one where a guy wouldn't like this he
goes and the wife goes but it was every
dude that walked by skipped on staring
at her that [ __ ] was [ __ ] then have
you caught yourself doing it no my mom
because when I walk like I don't ever
see
I don't ever see Joe checking girls out
I mean jobar [ __ ] I don't like Jesse
yeah yes Jesse check me so if I see like
a really like beautiful girl like I
won't be like damn looks like oh she's
pretty
you know it's it's what I think I moved
past that phase now I've seen he's
actually commented he'll be like that
girl is really [ __ ] beautiful and
that's kind of it yeah like I don't
really like [ __ ] at lemon I don't know
what it is but this is thing you know
yeah I mean maybe because like Instagram
kind of like this senses this sensitizes
you now because you see it so often here
it's just like alright it's a pretty
person you know well also being in LA
because like if you're in Vegas like a
lot of people are from like the Midwest
or some like tiny town like where
everyone looks a certain way and then
they're in Vegas and it's like whoa dude
were the biggest yeah what if everyone's
turned I can not even that bridge I'll
be walking how do you get that blonde
streak is that real for the bleach
paintings you know every person that I
bring around a girl that I bring around
Gio they always say the same thing
they're like oh my gosh she is so
beautiful I can't stop staring at her a
bit
[Laughter]
it's with every legit every [ __ ] girl
that I brought him I give him all your
same [ __ ] thing dude they're like
what they say about me and TIFF huh I
masturbate to them consistently every
yeah it's just a different they're yours
a little more perverse they look at her
as if she's like some kind of like Greek
statue that they've never seen me like
from that Island that Wonder Woman's
from yeah I was on like the whole Wonder
Woman what's her name again am I on
blinking kale yeah gal gadot yeah cuz
every time i every time i see her that's
the effect that she gives me I'm just
like she's so very I guess that her
forever like when we were in Vegas right
and you know that night everybody
dressed up she wouldn't stop talking
about you she's just like she's like
what does officiant when they when they
when they like get a track not
attractive but they're like mesmerized
by other women
exactly cuz like if I see a well-dressed
man I don't go like that [ __ ]
sexy yeah cuz when I see like a really
good-looking guy yeah must be nice
[ __ ] like it was a group of male
models last night when I was at this
karaoke event right like a bunch of like
and they were like half Asian Asians but
then there were girls there too but to
me they were just like guys yeah they're
like oh those are tall good-looking guys
well bar would know cuz remember you
passed by the construction dudes in
Europe and you're like Dan they're
really good-looking yeah and also
everytime I was going through Instagram
and I see the Siddartha brothers I'm
like god damn good-looking [ __ ]
I do notice them but I don't it doesn't
have an effect like they're these are
just people yeah that's how I feel right
way but then when I see girls though I'm
like yeah but it so everyone has like
their thing about them like what is the
accented thing like what like you know
like oh like eyes of a girl like that
might be her highlight thing I'm like
whoa she's got crazy eyes I'm also
looking at I want to romance novels like
and then when I saw her I said yeah like
if I'm looking at things right like
there's so much sense is going on in
Vegas nice cars [ __ ] lights all these
things right so I'm like [ __ ] lights
and [ __ ] damn she got long legs
[ __ ] Oh play craps and [ __ ] damn that's
a kitty but she kind of crazy yes is
dude my oh hush her skirts is short
damn and I'll go over here like that's a
fat family good luck in it you're
[ __ ] crazy like a museum for a Joe
dude it's like thought explosion that's
basically what's going on like you
seventy Sam's in his
[Music]